la comunidad israelí celebra el Día de
Jerusalén evento que conmemora la toma
de Jerusalén este tras la guerra de seis
días de 1967 los nacionalistas israelíes
muchos de ellos jóvenes se dirigieron
hasta la puerta de Damasco la entrada de
la ciudad vieja en esta marcha de la
bandera para la población israelí este
día tiene un valor festivo importante
estoy feliz de estar en Jerusalén y en
el día de Jerusalén celebrando 56 años
de tener nuestra ciudad natal y se puede
ver que la atmósfera es increíble
estamos aquí porque esta es nuestra
Patria y nuestra ciudad Santa
sin embargo supone un aliciente
detención más con los palestinos quienes
montaron sus propias movilizaciones en
sijordania y gaza inclusive algunas
procesiones se llevaron a cabo a sólo
metros de la valla que se para Israel de
territorio gasati la marcha de las
banderas no les traerá la soberanía
sobre Jerusalén que convirtieron en una
base militar Jerusalén seguirá siendo la
capital eterna y unidad de Palestina
Jerusalén seguirá siendo árabe e
islámica y la ocupación no tiene cabida
en la tierra de Palestina
las autoridades desplegaron más de 3.000
agentes de policía para prevenir
incidentes en un contexto donde los
enfrentamientos entre israelíes y
palestinos han aumentado en las últimas
semanas dejando más de una treintena de
Muertos lo que llevó a que ambos bandos
declararan una tregua al pasado fin de
semana